Now, my friends always tell me that a Japanese...
...is really good at balancing tradition and modernity.
So today, we would like to see whether this is true or not.
And our first stop will be Senso-ji.
So we're now at Senso-ji.
It's one of the oldest temples in Tokyo,...
...and dates back to 1,400 years ago.
So to my upper right, you see a big, red lantern.
You can't leave a temple without trying some local food.
So we are now on our way to try out some tasty snacks.
Are you ready?
Ningyo-yaki. These are Japanese traditional sweets, and I'm trying it now.
Oh, it's packed.
Look at this thing.
Actually, there are a variety of shapes,...
...so it's fun to discover different types of shapes.
How does it taste like?
I like this, it's really nice.
What's inside? Can you show it to me?
Yeah.
So I see there's red beans.
Yeah, it's filled with anko, which is sweet, smooth red bean paste.
And I like it so please try it.
It's popular in Asakusa.
Oh, this is funny.
Before entering the temple,...
...we saw a boy trying to get the smoke of incense onto his head.
This is a spirit cleansing ritual, I guess.
In the temple, we did a prayer in Buddhist style.
You know, when you're in Rome, you gotta do what the Romans do.